hello and welcome to this video playing
dennis
carpo hero carpo hero
let's play some of my d4 repertoire
get some reversed grunfeld
[Music]
yeah bishop d7 is the way to go here for
black but
many people take on e5 or even on d4
in particular knight takes d4 i find
really curious because
if the opponent blitzes out everything
it is an im would they really blunder
that pawn
okay e3 wins the rook then
or whatever a piece enough
okay so bishop d7 is the correct move
let's see what dennis is playing for now
never played him right no
[Music]
fairly it's not a new account just looks
a little bit like it
so here white has a standard way of
developing bishop f4 queen b3
with the rooks here and then exert so
much pressure on the queen side that
you should be fine okay so
i can take b7 here or not
it's been it's been a while since i
looked at the theory here when i wrote
the book
i mean wrote the chess of a course first
of all
and then the print book
let's see what he does so it takes f4
e2 is hanging with a check so
i should probably take this first
and now those two are hanging so
am i not just winning material here
what's going on 95
95
i'm on that bishop and i'm on that rook
right so
i should win some material here
i can make a pre-move them
yeah here and
here so up in exchange i guess
so oops let's unpaint this um
there's also b3m but then rook b8 is
coming
i still you have to be
um precise technically
always have to respect the two bishops
but yeah it's it's really it's it's
really winning by a mile
here
[Music]
can take d4 take e6 yeah i will i will
just take
take those pawns
i totally blundered the rook
ouch
okay the good news is the position is
still very good
but it was not intended
[Music]
okay
okay
[Music]
let's think about this so
i would like to get the king closer
[Music]
it's one of those cases where you should
try to devise a setup
there's this classic kappa blanket game
with the knight on d4 and rook c5 and b4
i don't remember the opponent
and it's it's kind of it's kind of
comparable this rook c5 b4 a3 and then
slowly push black back i'm a pawn up so
i don't really have to reinvent the
wheel here just like
have to be um
cautious and prevent any counter play
the rook is ideal here right on a5
attacking this
and stopping any g5 business
yeah that is a very good way to organize
things
so look here keep the pressure on the a
pawn
if he goes there go f4
the winning majority i mean i could have
tried e4 king e3 f4 e5 but
i just want to at the moment keep things
totally under control and
slowly push this to a victory
king to d2
so that i'm okay wants to go g5
this is an interesting moment maybe rook
a6
that stops g5
yeah and it will stop g5 for good yeah
cannot ever do it
because of that that pin
um now g5 i can take
twice till the h pawn will become mobile
but this is actually a moment for e4
king e3 right
yeah so that i get the square
i get the square
uh oh i actually forgot that i don't
i'm not on that anymore with the rook
okay
yeah it's it's still it's still
excellent okay f2 king e3 is very good
and h4 i i have this yeah i can
get the rook over there
and and i can push the e pawn as well
but what is the
best way to do it this does this
yeah this is good
and just stop that pawn
i thought rook h4 but that's not
actually threatening anything
hmm i didn't do this so well i'm i'm i'm
kind of happy with the start of my
conversion
but this is not really ideal
king f4 is got h2 for christ's sake
h2
king f2h2k2 rook t1
what am i playing wow crazy
crazy
that is technical play from hell really
what i'm doing here
it could still win actually it's not
impossible but it's just like
awful really awful
hmm
oh my god damn
yeah rook c7 is a draw but i really
don't see anything else now
wait here i can try king f6 without any
particular risk
[Music]
check
okay that that deals left to draw
i should go to the short side check
that was such an awful game
that was so bad how on earth
did i allow that and and the start of
the technical conversion was actually
kind of okay
but i mean i okay let's just start here
right because that is actually
instructive so
i i did it right yeah didn't give him
any counter play
just like total control
and i'm quite happy with all that
and then like b4 well it cannot be bad
yeah
e4 g5 and now for christ's sake
i take take take h4 let's let's win this
now yeah
king e3 that i
think should be fine h3 rook h6
rook f1 and then i really panicked badly
for some reason so a4
rook h1
king f4 h2
so i should just take that thing
and win with the pawns yeah i saw that
but i felt
i totally panicked king e5
it still wins
it still wins it was just like so
unnecessary
okay what wins is this
and like here here and then i have like
a million pawns so
yeah that wins but okay this
also should win knight f5 and that was
not so difficult
okay i had two seconds so
this and knight f5 is always just
winning
and this also should win why do i go
back king d6
okay three seconds but still kidney six
is kind of obvious
yeah should try to promote yours your
pawns
okay i go back
and
still pressing
ah now i should take okay well i don't
have much time but still
like this because he cannot take as this
is a made threat it's a
known idea
okay i went to f6 with
no time on the clock okay one
yeah and that that should win right
i kind of made my life a little bit
difficult
um but it was always winning
you know and you get to get to promote
man that was one of the worst technical
plays ever
really yeah the time yeah and
what i got totally panicky here going
down to two seconds
oh my god okay guys thanks for watching